welcome back to the gamespot stage here
at e3 2016 brought to you by airheads
bites joining tomorrow and I to talk a
little bit about Xbox design lab is
Monique welcome to welcome to the stage
thank you so this is a brand new
initiative for Xbox we've never really
been able to customize your controllers
to this kind of degree before where did
that come from like whose idea was it
how long ago um well it's it's been like
a crazy journey which actually this idea
has come up over and over for the past
like three or four years but never
before have we been able to get like
sort of all of the pieces together to do
this this very like front-end like you
know customization experience all the
way through to the back end
manufacturing to be able to deliver
these kind of custom designs straight to
people's doors so it's been brought up a
number of times but this particular time
it's been about it's been about 16
months since I've been working on this
so over a year yeah we started we first
started my just going out and talking to
fans about what how they would like to
customize their controllers you know
what the best ways to do that might be
and it turns out that color is something
that really resonates with everyone and
you're actually an industrial design all
right yeah what's that what's that mean
for people who might not know industrial
designers and how does that transfer
over being able to give us this
cool-looking uh controllers well
industrial design is like designed for
mass production so it's sort of like
we're sculpture and color and materials
meets engineering so it's just like
super cool blend of like art and science
yes yeah so um so this is one aspect of
industrial design but like a typical
industrial designer like would design
the whole product right no you said that
the big thing that fans were clamoring
for was color how do you kind of decide
on what sort of shades to go down like
not like whether it was it within a
certain kind of palette of color was it
just really bright ones you want to get
your attention how do you decide well
you know it was interesting because we
want
to do a really broad palette that
allowed any of our like diverse fans to
express any type of story or any you
know any type of vision that they wanted
to but then at the same time we wanted
to make sure that everything really hung
together and looked looked good together
so it's definitely a lot of just a lot
of work like developing the specific
pigments we know that people love color
for different reasons like some people
just like they have their favorite color
it might be pink you love pink you want
everything in pink and you're just like
to make a pink controller or it might be
related to a game you play you might
drive a blacked-out car you might play
Forza and you just want to block out
your controller yeah it might just be
something cool that you've seen so we
wanted to provide you know options for
for everyone and so some of the colors
that are more popular like blue we have
33 different blues so you can do a dark
like a dark neutral you can do like a
super bright sporty photon blue or you
can do more of the more of a pastel blue
and they were great together but then
they also work great with the other
accent colors um yeah Green was also a
big one for us that's an important
obviously their eggs angrier yeah so we
have two greens um I think the best
thing about is that like people are
already creating color schemes like I've
seen a whole range of overwatch color
schemes to you know sue every character
which is amazing for me because I'm
hopeless at making cool-looking things
that we've got some amazing everything I
make is disgusting and gross it's like
why I canvas it's like a book of green
controller and why would I ever want
this but like there's like we've got a
gallery up on our website ready of just
like game specific stuff and like theme
specific stuff and like being able to
express yourself and have a controller
that's uniquely your own is it's like
it's a cool thing that everyone can get
behind like you never really know that
you want to call it control until you
hold it in your hand and it says your
name on there like XX pro sniper 10 or
whatever is you're like yep right yeah
take a close look that ones you brought
with you yeah just brought a few
examples of the kinds of things that you
can build um yeah so this is just an
example of two blues that look great
together a bright orange
as you know mmm yeah I thought orange
might be able to cut for this year yeah
yeah and it's like a super bright
vibrant orange we've got we've got
Gray's blues blacks whites like a lot of
neutrals and then some really fun pop
colors it looks like the the actual
names on here are generated by the same
generator that we use for gamertags so
like storm yay new Sasquatch new
Sasquatch what's that one this one's a
pirate drop out all over Paris are
probably drop outs to be there so do we
get you get to chance the right what's
on your controller right yeah what is
that I'm assuming they'll be no
obscenities how long does that list run
to make sure that people don't just sort
of yeah it's actually the same the same
engine that we use to check texts as we
use on the gamer tags all right yes I
was in automated right so it's 16
characters so you can put your gamer tag
on it or a message they make great gifts
yes I heard so many stories just working
the booth and talking to people like
over the past year someone was just
saying to me yesterday like when my
roommate plays he gets he gets angry and
I always ask him are you angry are you
angry so I'm gonna make him a controller
and say are you angry yeah you know it's
like everybody has their you know little
personal things and it's like super fun
to just pop the controller off yeah
something personal but it's not just the
color that you continue you know change
the colors of like the face buttons
everything to do with that all right I
didn't know so the individual face
buttons also customizable right so you
can do the the top and side cases bottom
case front front area with the triggers
you can do thumbsticks d-pads a B X Y
and and view menu so there are 15 colors
for the main parts 30 there's a subset
of eight of those colors for the
thumbsticks and then a B X Y and view
menu there's there's five and four
versions so says the the new controller
that was unveiled with the xbox one s
yes is this gonna be retro actively put
into like the original xbox one
controller and is it going to work with
the elite controller um this controller
is compatible with all of the game
systems and this is a controller that
was just announced it's the one with the
the grip on it in the bluetooth
um audio jack everything I think it's is
what for people who play in like compare
tournaments it might be an idea to
create like the most obnoxious looking
one to psych out their opponent by going
there with like a bread fiery whines
constantly waving yeah this is it wanna
play that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
get a horrendous looking one right so I
can't my for my opponents but obviously
you can get some cool looking ones right
our team colors yeah there also were
mere sasur look at the brand new gears
of war controller I seem Xbox is still
gonna be releasing game specific ones is
there going to be any crossover with
these ones I am I guess we'll have to
see how the system develops you know
we've we've put the color out there as
our as our platform and we're just
waiting to see what the reaction is
which I think it's going to be great
based on what I've been hearing at the
show um but yet we're waiting to see how
things sort of work out and then we'll
we'll figure out what comes next I think
you know the possibilities are endless
and people are gonna find their own
creative ways to use the system I mean
there's a big like audience and a market
out there for like decals and that kind
of stuff so is that something you guys
have thought about in the future I'd
love to be able to put my own little
stickers and designs on them as well
yeah we've we've definitely thought
about it I can't like really you know
disclose any future plans but it's all
you know there's a lot there are a lot
of different ways to take this so yeah
is it any scope for may be expanding it
to the xbox one box console itself I
mean because you've got the PlayStation
4 you can have faceplates which is a
kind of customization but if this seems
like the first step you know too I mean
people love it when things are
customized for themselves right right
well we're you know we're seeing how
this goes and we're looking for people's
feedback and then you figure out you
know what makes what makes the best
business sense but we we love delivering
you know the the product or the visions
that the the fans want so I think the
more the more people are asking for
things the more likely it is that you
know we're gonna we're going to be able
to execute on this so what you're saying
is to start a petition yeah start a riot
okay on that okay well
so I petition chase dog change the org
yeah so the the customization software
is the interactive experience is as
super easy and super intuitive and I
don't know if so you have gotten a
chance to try it out I have you I think
everyone has created their own unique
one and I think they were available to
try at the microsoft event earlier where
I did try and make some book promptly
got kicked off by someone with more
artistic talent than me okay okay yeah
so from creation to shipping to delivery
how long is that process estimated to
take I see me like it's not launching
for a little bit and there will be a
backlog right at the at the moment if
you preorder you will receive your
controller in September but after this
pre-order window is over it will be 14
days between pressing order and having
it delivered to your doorstep that's
actually not it's pretty yeah it's
pretty great for getting your own you
know custom build of the controller
pretty amazing any terms of pricing do
you know how much it uh yeah it's 79 99
and it's an extra 999 for the engraving
awesome cool um what kind of things were
there other things you Kate maybe wanted
to change about the controller this
program that maybe weren't applicable to
like a mass-market kind of engineering
project um well we settled on going we
kind of started the program just looking
for the best way to offer a
customization platform and we settled on
color because it's something that that
really resonates with everyone it's like
we have this super diverse fan base
playing all sorts of games different
genders different ages into different
things but like everyone that we talked
to has it has this like emotional
visceral response to color so it just
seemed like the the best like most broad
way to reach everyone um you've got
you've got a whole bunch of colors here
but do you think that you'll be maybe
continuing to ad mortem or is this kind
of like the set color scheme you know I
think as time goes on well we'll have to
know take a look at the colors and keep
up with yeah just sort of the culture
the
and then trends and yeah I think I think
this is probably going to be an evolving
business for us you must have done some
research at some point to find out what
the most popular color is can you
finally settle that debate oh yeah yeah
is it green uh I I definitely know that
in the Xbox community there's like
there's an affinity for green yeah but
the most popular color it seems it
always bubbles up as blue oh really yeah
people people love Lil it's a calming
common kind of color so when you're
playing gears of war and just seeing
stuff explode from you just have a look
down just kind of looked at recenter
yourself yeah remember where you are in
life carry on right or you can you read
in black yeah yeah red and black want to
channel some of that for you kind of
yeah it's good like Xbox don't concern
at all that they're moving away from
like that call Brandon yeah that's kind
of interest I'm you know it was a big
discussion in our studio um you know
should we do this or should we not do
this but it kind of just comes down to
doing things for the fans and like
appreciating the fact that like people
people love to express themselves you
know people find different ways to do it
it's like the way you speak the people
you know the activities you participate
in the clothes you wear the products you
surround yourselves with and and our
products are they're super important to
some people you know they're like a big
part of people's lives so just kind of
creating creating a platform out of our
products like a platform for expression
and we just kind of came around as a
design studio to understand that like
that's something really really special
and something that we want to be part of
so yes and no yeah what I'm thinking is
like in the future if you could sort it
the way you can create custom decals and
things I could sort of see that is that
like the next thing that maybe you guys
end up doing with this because that
seems like a really cool opportunity
people to express themselves even more
if this you know takes off and already
looks like it has by the reaction right
yeah yeah I mean it's definitely been a
conversation we've definitely talked
about things like that but I couldn't I
couldn't say that anything's for sure
you know we'll just we're kind of seeing
how seeing how this goes and then
so you can pre-order now right exactly
yeah so you can you can go on to xbox
design lab xbox calm and design your own
controller and you can save it you can
save it to a gallery or you can save it
to any you know through social media and
you can order order at any time that's
one super cool part of the customization
site is that you can go into the
community gallery and you can you can
see what people have created you can be
inspired and you can you can start from
there so you can start from a blank
controller if you just want to clean
slate and if you need a bit of
inspiration you can start from something
that's been created in the community and
then kind of make it your own how long
is that pre-order window when do you
anticipate you'll be closing it um I
think it's some time in September it
goes I don't know the exact date right
moni what person personally what color
controller would you create going to the
lab I'd you know I've made so many of
them and then there was a formal beta
that came through the group and I just I
decided to make one for for my son and
he's he's five and he loves to race a
yellow car he loves to play forza so i
didn't make one for myself but i made
one for him and it was like super fun to
just think about what he would like and
what's like appropriate for him yeah so
that's the one that's the one that I've
kind of created to take home it's yellow
it's yellow and grey it's it's got a
little engraving on it awesome I think I
might replicate this because it's making
me feel at peace you feel calm i'm gonna
kick i might just keep this movie well
thank you so much for joining us
obviously then it goes when when we
leave be receiving the first batch of
controllers out in the pan out in the
wild so the first batch in the wild
should be in September anybody that
pre-orders now should should get their
controllers in September thank you so
much guarantee thank you I'm more
coverage from this year's e3 of course
make sure you stay tuned to gamespot com